hello thank you for coming to my talk so
my name is Lisa I'm a web developer and
sort of a maker hacker I make things for
fun and I'm a super fan of space
exploration and so today I'm going to
talk about a few different ways to find
space mission data on the web space
finding space mission data on the web
can be tricky there's a lot of it
we've sent nearly 200 robotic missions
to space since starting around 1958 this
infographic shows sort of the orbits
that we've done around various planets
in our solar system the biggest circle
there on the left is Mars we've done a
lot of exploration of Mars less so in
the outer solar system there on the
right
so and one reason it's tricky to find
data is space missions are enormous
collaborations from the people that work
on the spacecraft itself to the
engineering to the science and the
planning and analysis literally a cast
of thousands work on every single
mission and if you think about a
spacecraft it's this vehicle that we've
flung into space and we attached to it
several instruments this is a diagram of
the Cassini orbiter and all its
instruments and sometimes there can be
up to a dozen instruments on every
spacecraft and these are highly
specialized instruments they and there
can be quite a learning curve to
learning about the data that they
collect each instrument has its own team
of people that work primarily on that
instrument sometimes instrument team
members don't even talk to other members
on other instruments there they're just
that highly specialized and it's usually
the instrument teams that Shepherd the
data from space out to the web and out
to the public so it can be very
distributed all over the web but I'm
going to give you a sort of a landscape
view of where I see are sort of three
different areas
we're makers and hackers and
experimentalists can find data to make
things there's three general areas
search tools api's and web scraping I'm
going to talk about search tools first
search tools are like web forms you go
to a website you fill out a form and
maybe you can view some data and do some
downloads there are thousands of these
on the web they vary widely in usability
they serve different communities they're
there they vary widely and I'm going to
show you one that I'm intimately
familiar with because I work on it for
my day job so I work for the NASA
planetary data system that's the program
of NASA to take space mission data from
planetary probes and put it on the web
release it to the public and work with
the science community on using it it's
divided into disciplinary nodes so
there's a small bodies node and they
focus on asteroids comets and
interplanetary dust and there's a
geosciences node they have a lot of they
have all the Mars data and images and
there's an atmospheres node and they
deal with non-imaging atmospheres
atmospheric data and they would note
that I work for is the ring immune
systems node our planet our leadership
are experts in planetary ring moon
systems so there's a whole community of
people who study the outer planets and
ring moon systems so most people are
aware that Saturn has these gorgeous
iconic rings you can see them from
earth-based telescopes but not everyone
realizes that Jupiter Uranus and Neptune
also have ring systems they're very
faint rings at these planets so our node
archives data from all missions that
visit any ring any planet with rings so
we have all the data for from for
instance the New Horizons mission even
though that mission was primarily to go
to Pluto
it had a very cool encounter at Jupiter
2 so we archive all that data as well so
we made a search tool and in fine NASA
tradition we gave it an acronym opus
stands for outer planets unified search
and the idea behind it is that we've
combined several missions into one
interface and the problem we were trying
to solve is that we noticed that in the
planetary rings community that people
were having to have a lot of web and
spacecraft instrument domain knowledge
just to find the data they were looking
for to study say a moon of Saturn or the
planet Jupiter and we wanted to make an
interface that let them focus more on
what they were trying to study and and
bring together a bunch of datasets
together to make it a little easier so
I'll just jump into demoing it for you
so the landing page is probably my least
favorite page of the website it's just
really complex so we're funded to serve
primarily scientific research community
so there are some very specialized
features and it's rather complicated and
my bad joke is that it looks like a DMV
form but the UX is hard right design is
hard but the idea is this you start with
all access to all our results so in the
top blue bar if you can see at the top
there's a big number that I think it's
1.2 million when I made this slide
that's a count of everything in our
database so for this tool we archive the
complete set of remote sensing data for
several NASA missions Voyager probes
Galileo New Horizons and Cassini and
there's some Hubble datasets in there as
well and the idea is that you want to
search and narrow down your results to
like a more reasonable number than 1.2
million based on what you're looking for
so that you can browse and maybe do some
downloading of data the left column is
this sort of monster list of parameters
so when a spacecraft takes a picture it
records with it a lot of metadata with
that picture the pointing angle of the
camera the angle between the Sun
and the target and the spacecraft and a
bunch of spacecraft state data so we've
made it possible to search absolutely
all those fields so that's why there's a
lot of things in there and the idea is
that you you can click on one of those
and it brings up a widget in the middle
so there's two widgets showing right now
planet and target target means like moon
or ring and so the idea is that you can
search by those parameters by clicking
and filling out a widget so I'll show
you what I mean I'll go ahead and click
Jupiter here and the first thing you
might notice is that the number at the
top got a lot smaller because you're
basically saying show me only results
marked tagged Jupiter and the other
thing that happened is the target list
for Jupiter open so you can see all the
moons that all the observations that
we've identified as being of moons so
then I'm just going to stop there and
click click the number click the Browse
results and what you get is sort of this
infinitely scrolling gallery of space
images the default order here is
ascending in time so what you're seeing
here is actually the earliest
observations in our database and the and
this is so this is Voyager 1 on its
approach to Jupiter it's just opened its
shuttered doors and started imaging
Jupiter as it approaches so the Voyager
mission was to identical spacecraft
Voyager 1 and Voyager 2 they were
launched a few months apart in the late
70s Voyager 1 was the first to reach
Jupiter both want an original mission to
explore Jupiter and Saturn and they
actually went on later to explore
Neptune and Uranus as well and Voyager 1
actually having begun its mission as an
interplanetary probe in our solar system
has actually left the solar system
becoming humanity's first interstellar
probe so I'm going to skip ahead you can
infinitely scroll or you can you can
enter page numbers so I've skipped ahead
here about 125 pages forward in pages
and forward in time
so this is still Voyager 1 it's gotten
much closer to Jupiter now and it's
taking these very detailed close-ups of
Jupiter's atmosphere and it's sort of
weird clouds and storms that happen all
over Jupiter so I want to say a bit
about the color you might be picking up
in these thumbnails space imaging
cameras are most often black-and-white
cameras with a black-and-white camera
you can pick up a lot more information
at each pixel than with a color camera
and the way they detect color is they
have a filter wheel in front of the
camera and so they'll drop in colored
filters and those filters allow them to
measure intensities of light at
different wavelengths or different
colors so for this gallery we've given a
false color tint to these thumbnails
just as a visual cue to let you know
what filter was used in that image and
I'll talk a bit in a minute about why
that's useful so I'm going to jump into
a similar search for Saturn this time
I've checked Saturn instead of Jupiter
and the number at the top is now pretty
large and that's because most of the
images in our database are taken near
the Saturn system and that's because of
the Cassini mission so Cassini launched
20 years after the voyagers left Earth
they arrived and entered orbit around
Saturn in July 2004 and they completed
it completed just under 300 orbits
before just a few weeks ago the mission
ended and they plowed the spacecraft
into Saturn so this spacecraft doesn't
exist anymore but we've got half a
million pictures from it and data and
the science from this mission will go on
for decades it's probably um so these
are images from Cassini so when I say
orbits generally when you think of an
orbit like an earth satellite and almost
all the Mars satellites orbit at the
same elevation above the planet for
their lifetime but to study something
like Saturn and its rings you really
need some different orbits so Cassini
did these crazy orbits the reason is if
you're always in the same plane like if
you're in this
same plane as the rings you'll always
just see this straight line so you
really have to get around to different
angles in order to study Saturn's rings
and and the other reason is there's
there's 150 moons and moonlets at total
around around Saturn around 50 have been
given official names and around 60 have
known orbits so a lot of these these
orbits are planned to swing by these
moons and really study those moons some
of them are have possible could could
Harbor life very interesting moons out
there around Saturn um one thing I love
about Cassini also is in terms of this
interface is it's a very stable platform
for imaging cameras so as you browse
through Cassini images you can see many
sequences actually that just look like
frames of a movie so here's a sequence
where Cassini was imaging the tiny moon
Atlas it's a tiny moon that that orbits
within the Rings and if you click the
larger preview and just kind of hold
down the right arrow key if you have a
good internet connection you can sort of
see this animation effect so that's a
that's Atlas as it's sort of flying
around its orbit at Saturn so there are
many sequences like this and people have
used opus to make frame animation movies
adding music beds getting really
creative without having to do any extra
processing work to stabilize the scene
in the frame um here's an example this
is Greg Pugh he is lightning rod on
YouTube and he's made these animations
he's found a lot of these and he adds
music and releases these on YouTube you
should definitely check out his videos
um so I'm going to do one more example
of a search that's really common and
that's an instrument search and that's
where we add an instrument so I'm going
to click instrument and that's where you
want to narrow it down to one spacecraft
so I'm gonna select New Horizons here
and then Jupiter and then I want to look
at Jupiter's moon Io and then we'll see
the results here so these are images of
Io the demo in this gallery or this
gallery is actually a shopping cart so
you can select images from here and add
them to your collection
and then click the collection tab at the
top to view what you've selected and you
can download a zip file or a CSV so some
of you might be familiar with the New
Horizons mission because it just visited
Pluto last year and gave us our first
images of Pluto we never knew what Pluto
looks like before but it really also had
a cool encounter at Jupiter 2
and I'll show you what I mean here so if
you look if you can see at the top of at
the top of Io there's like that bright
bump so it turns out that's actually a
volcano that is erupting as New Horizons
was taking pictures of it this was not
planned you always hope that when you
look at IO you see something because we
do know it's volcanic Li active but this
was just a stroke of luck that as New
Horizons was leaving the Jupiter system
and turned around and looked at i/o
backlit by the Sun that it picked up
this plume so from this set of frames
this is we get the only existing frame
animation movie of a volcano erupting on
another world so that's a - I go right
so that plume is 200 miles high and it's
a little bit over the horizon so we're
just seeing the top and its name is Tov
a star I think it's a cool name
so other uses for some of those
parameters that we saw you can narrow
down resolutions and phase angle so
lighting angles so these were made by
Emily Locke diwali of the planetary
society she's a scientist and science
journalist and she creates these images
that are collections of different
planetary bodies in the same image to
show scale comparisons and to teach and
raise awareness about our solar system
so that's one thing um speaking of okay
here sorry there's also a thriving
community of people who create color
versions of space probe images so space
probe cameras are black and white and
they have color filters you use to pick
up different intensities of light at
different wavelengths it turns out if
you can find three images taken with the
red green and blue filter of the same
scene you can actually create color
images so there's a community of people
who do this as hobbyists here's one by
Ian Regan he has a whole collection of
these here's one by Valerie clave ins so
they they meet online and I'll give you
some resources later but this is a this
is a really cool thing and so this is
sort of the color that you might see if
with your eyes if you were out there you
need just some photoshop skills and some
judgment calls because we all see color
differently but a lot of the images that
you see in the press the colorized
versions of space images are done by
hobbyist community people speaking of
image processing and movies there isn't
a large format I have IMAX movie coming
out so they're not using any like 3d
rendering or CGI or anything like that
to make this movie instead they're
processing over seven and a half million
photographs taken from actual spacecraft
and telescopes so I'm going to play
it's gonna get very motioning here for a
second
so during production they used opus to
find suitable image sets to stitch
together into very large-scale panoramas
to create the effect of flying through
space around Saturn so this movie is
actually due out I think later this year
early next year so definitely Google
it's called in Saturn's rings so like I
said we're part of the planetary data
system they have a central website
there's a lot of search tools you can
explore there's a search box up there in
the right corner where put anything in
there Mars Jupiter whatever you are
curious about and you'll get a list of
search tools so that's something to
think about but if you're lucky there's
an API
I like api's so I'll talk about API so
opus has an API it's completely just
open JSON API requests over HTTP any
search should be can be performed in
opus can be performed as an API called
the URL structure is the same so you can
access anything at opus through the API
so I'll show you a quick example this is
our data endpoint I'm asking for data in
JSON here and I'm doing a search planet
equals Saturn and I want to look at the
target Hyperion that's a moon of Saturn
and put that issue that call and you'll
get a JSON response and you can
customize these values that you get back
here's another example this is our
images API so I'm asking here for medium
images in HTML format just so I can show
you them and I've just added a parameter
of the instrument I want to see Cassini
images and you'll get these uh pictures
of Hyperion which is Saturn's weird
spongy moon so if you wanted to grab a
lot of images this would be a way to do
it if you change that dot HTML to dot
JSON you'll get a JSON response which
with direct links to all the image URLs
so that's a good way to grab images and
math the way you get there is you go to
our landing page there's a link at
bottom tiny link and we have an API
guide which has those examples and many
more on how to use it
um so people are using it there's a
couple of Twitter BOTS
this one is planetary bot it this one's
by Garrett Berenson he's an astronomer
with NASA's Kepler k2 mission and he's a
hacker and he made this but he chose to
go with the color images the tinted
images we also have the full res
black-and-white images in our API but he
said he just liked the way that the
colorized versions looked and I love
this spot because I also love how did
the emojis in the tweet it's pretty cool
here's another bot I love this is the
ephemeris by Alison Parrish
she spoke here yesterday great talk
about computer generated poetry you
should definitely check it out if you
didn't if you didn't make it yesterday
she's a computer programmer poet
educator at game dev university
instructor her teaching and practice
address the unusual phenomenon that
blossom when language and computers meet
definitely worth checking out her work
she made this bought the ephemerides and
she says quote the idea behind the bot
was to address the similarity between
space probes and generative poetry
procedures from the opposite direction
what would poetry written by a space
probe look like I love this bot so much
generative poetry so she went with the
full res black and white images and she
said quote I love the raw images somehow
they seem warmer and more personal to me
which fits into the fiction of the bot
that these poems are a personal
documentation of the probes own
experience so definitely check that out
she's got a great blog post that
explains more about the generative
poetry involved in making the spot so
there are other api's out there you
should definitely check out NASA's data
portal it's at data eásá gov they have a
bunch of api's here and a bunch of a
list of search tools and a lot of
resources I want to show you one a
little path through here because I found
it a little bit hard to find but it's
really cool
if you click data catalog and
Datta lens I have no idea what that
means but what you get is this list of
datasets and I'm gonna click one here
that is meteorite landings and you get
this page with like a map of the
landings these are meteorites hitting
Earth but there's also this link to an
API and if you click that you'll get
just directly linked to the JSON
endpoint um and there's they also have
really good documentation so like they
have this page that shows you how to
work with JSON endpoints and it even has
like a Python snippet that you can just
cut and paste so this is worth checking
out dated nasa.gov so those are
documented API is the public is invited
to use them anybody can find them and
there's you know they're well documented
sometimes there's an undocumented API
you can find so I'll tell you a story
about something I worked on where we
used an undocumented undocumented API
from NASA
so my friend and collaborator Ariel
Waldman and I we make space space things
and we were between projects and we
wanted to make something new and there's
something that we thought didn't exist
on the web and we won't really wanted to
see it and that was a website that will
tell you what are all the live active
space missions that are out there right
now NASA has their own websites where
they list their their space probes but
there are several countries with space
missions there's the United States has
NASA of course but China Japan India and
the European Space Agency which is a
collaboration of 22 Member States all
have active space probes out there so we
wanted to make a site where you can see
like what are all the space probes that
are actually out there still chirping
back to earth there's a wikipedia page
it does a pretty good job but we're web
designers and and we love beautiful
things and we wanted to make just like a
really cool beautiful site I was super
inspired by this site how many people
are in space right now com
there's six it's just one of these
simple sir single serving sites if you
scroll down you'll you can learn a
little bit more about the astronauts but
I really love the idea of just being
connected and real-time to what's going
on in space and I wanted to see
something like this for the probes so we
bought a domain
thank you country of Spain for that dot
es au domain name and we made this
website my collaborator I'm not a
designer and more the techies she's a
fantastic visual designer and she came
up with these space craft silhouettes so
this site lists all the current active
space missions and we keep it up to date
if if a spacecraft crashes into its
target it's over we take it down if you
click one of those you get information
about the probe some links to learn more
a little bit of pictures about it and
again this is all countries but when we
were shopping this idea around to our
friends like what would you want to see
in a website about space probes we
overwhelmingly heard they want data ok
maybe our friends are nerds but people
wanted like a portal to all the space
probe data but that's very difficult to
do for for the reasons that I mentioned
before but also different countries have
different policies about releasing their
data but we did find sort of an
undocumented data source so the Deep
Space Network is this worldwide network
of radio telescopes there are three
locations
it's run by NASA they'd have contracts
with different countries and they just
track space probes all day long and they
have this awesome website deep space now
calm where you can see in real time what
the what spacecraft the dishes are
talking to so the three rows are the
three locations Madrid in Spain
Goldstone in California and Canberra in
Australia and if you click one of those
dishes like I've I've clicked one in the
Goldstone row it'll tell you information
about the spacecraft on the right-hand
side and because they're doing radio
pings back and forth they
oh the round-trip time travel speed so
they know the distance to that probe so
the pro basically reports its distance
so we thought that was a cool metric
like how far aware these are all the
probes that's kind of a real-time like
physical thing that we can think about
so we wanted that piece of information
for our site so we open up our developer
tools and sort of watch the site if you
if you just run this site in your
browser all day it'll it'll
automatically update itself to be sort
of real-time what the dishes are doing
but if you watch what it's doing it's
doing Ajax calls in the background to
another service and so it you know your
developer tools will show you the URL
its calling and so we grab that URL to
check it out and this is what we got
which is not super inspiring it's sort
of a wall of XML that was my response
but a Python to the rescue there's a
Python library called XML to dict it's
utility that turns XML into a Python
dictionary so doing it feeding it
through that now we can read it so the
top-level DSN deep space now and then
this is Canberra we know what that is
that's one of the locations and then a
list of dishes and then there's some
stuff about the dish the pointing angle
the wind speed its elevation and then
there's this target field and under that
is a name and we found this list of
space craft codes that related to their
names that's the URL if anybody wants it
but basically what this saying is it's
talking to Cassini when I took this
slide which was before Cassini got
destroyed and then there's this field up
leg range and there's also down leg
range I don't really know what up leg
and down leg but the range field matches
the number that they listed on that web
site range means the distance shortest
distance between two things
so that's actually a report of the
spacecraft distance so we put this
scraper basically up on Heroku turned on
a scheduler and in a week we had a full
database of all the spacecraft it turns
out they communicate rather often so
that spacecraft distance is
very near to the actual distance of the
spacecraft right now so that's how we're
able to order our website by furthest at
the top down to closest to Earth at the
bottom and we are able to show the
current distance to the to the craft and
we have these clicky things at the top
you can sort of reorder by launch date
which is hard-coded or by distance so
we're hitting our own API we made our
own sort of JSON Heroku Redis object
that we just are continually updating so
we're hitting our own API it's nice to
not send your own website traffic to
another to another website that's not
your own so we made our own API the last
area I want to talk about is web
scraping I really loves web scraping
projects especially for beginners - web
development because you get to write
some Python it's sort of a standalone
Python script but you're also sort of
forced to think about the way HTML is
structured and how people create pages
so when I was first learning Python I
did a few scraping projects
I used beautifulsoup it's a it's very
forgiving of broken old HTML and it's
just a very intuitive scraping tool for
Python and so I I usually recommend that
to people so here's an example of
something I've worked on that was a
scraping project so my same friend Ariel
Waldman and I excuse me we were in a
hackathon on the subject of Mars and so
we we found this website this is the
high-rise web site high-rise is an
instrument on the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter it takes absolutely gorgeous
photos and they put it on this website
this is very well structured HTML so
thanks high-rise team at Arizona State
but we wanted to make a we thought these
images were so beautiful like if you
click on one of these thumbnails you get
the full res image some get some caption
content information about it and the
image credit and but their website it's
a little bit like the thumbnails are
small there's no infinite scroll you
have to put
click-click so we wanted to make do
something more graphic and just really
bring out these images so we used
WordPress we had one day we scraped the
site we got this JSON file when we
scraped it using beautifulsoup
and then we sort of fed that into a
wordpress site and we made Mars from
space comm and again this is on like a
cron job or scheduler so it keeps up to
date with the highrise main web site and
we just wanted to have this really in
your face experience of these gorgeous
pictures and this is sort of one of
these long infinitely scrolling pages if
you click on one of those you get a very
big image and the content and the image
credit and a link back to the high-rise
web site and the way we did this is we
like WordPress because there's a really
there's there's a there's a huge
community of design themes that you can
buy off the shelf so you don't have to
design a website you can buy a theme and
just install it and if you're if you're
not familiar with WordPress it's
actually a blogging platform you sort of
log into the admin type of a blog post
upload an image and then you have a blog
but there's actually a lot of there's a
plug-in directory that extends the
functionality of WordPress so we use
this plugin we installed WordPress on a
wordpress site unlike DreamHost I think
and then we install this plug-in it's
called where is it
xml-rpc modernization that's quite a
name what it lets you do is basically
create wordpress posts on your own
machine with python and then send them
over the Internet to your WordPress site
and create a post so we looped through
our our scrape of the high-rise site and
and just created a post on our remote
WordPress site and so we let it run for
about an hour and a half and then we had
this website with all these images and
posts so that's kind of a good strategy
if you want to make a pretty website at
a hackathon in a shorter much time
so that's about it I have some resources
I want to tell you about I mentioned
data's nasa.gov there's a lot there the
Planetary Society has space imaging
process based image processing tutorials
so if you want to get into making
colorized versions and exploring space
images and looking at different planets
and I showed you you should definitely
check out Planetary org there's also a
really good blog post there by Emily
Locke to Walla where where to find
rapidly released space image data so
I've showed you some archival places but
these are there's also places where the
images are released very soon after they
hit Earth so those are worth checking
out
I want to mentioned NASA data knots
it's a program by NASA to improve the
usability of the data landscape at NASA
and to engage with the growing data tech
maker community they work with a group
of people each year I think they're
doing it twice a year now actually and
they're very generous with time and
resources to help people learn how to
find and use NASA data it began as part
of NASA's women and data focus intending
to create a safe space for newcomers to
data to the data science frontier
especially girls and women and it's open
to anyone now but it still very much has
that vibe so I would definitely
encourage you to check it out and
especially if you are an
underrepresented woman or person of
color who does anything with data
definitely check out NASA data knots
it's a great program and a great way to
connect with other people that are doing
this kind of work thank you so much I'm
happy to take questions afterwards
[Applause]